hi I'm RIA I'm a tasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy rolls are you
must use the food given you can only up
to the food you can buy whatever
ingredients you wish okay let's see
what's in there
drum roll boxed cake mix to be honest
I'm not a big fan of box cake mix my
Instagram handle name is the deserts
knob and the tops knob doesn't use box
cake mix so I think it's not that fun if
you just bake cake and decorate them
fancy so I want to make something very
different I want to change the texture
I'm gonna change the taste basically I'm
gonna change everything
hopefully my idea works hopefully I can
make it fancy here's what I got heavy
cream dark chocolate unsalted butter
next from the pantry I got sugar salt
and of course Grand Marnier all right
let's get started make it fancy so first
thing I'm going to chop some butter so
it melts faster I'm gonna keep this
wrapper for later and 1 cup of water
just a pinch so I'm going to bring this
to a boil and meanwhile I'm going to
measure out this cake mix so I'm going
to need 1 and 1/3 cup of box cake mix
and sift so it doesn't have any clumps
so it's boiling I'm gonna add this at
once lower heat I start smelling this
cake mix chemical smell so in order to
eliminate I'm going to add a little bit
of Grand Marnier just a little bit but
we will use this later
my producer Cyrus kind of asked me if I
can now use alcohol cause laughing
should I use a lot of alcohol but I want
to evaporate moisture in the dough this
is ready to hear sounds like a dough
boys belly I'm going to take off from
the heat and cool it down to touch so
I'm going to separate it whites and egg
yolk and for this I'm gonna just use
yolks I'm going to use white Slater's
I'm going to save it so if you put eggs
into hot dog egg will cook so I want to
make sure it is coated touch I'm going
to add yolks one by one and incorporate
so I'm going for a little bit runny
still not runny so I'm going to add more
yolks and I'm adding false york and a
little bit whites it's still a little
bit stiff so I'm gonna add 1/4 instead
of Jesse oh nice the indication is when
you scoop a big scoop and when it's kind
of like dropping yeah it's already there
so this is looking great so I'm moving
on to next step I got some sugar and
measuring this out it's 200 grams sugar
goes in the fall and I have 60 meter
water so what it's going I'm going to
measure 200 gram of egg whites and I
just have to wait my syrup to get boiled
so while I'm waiting I'm going to move
on to the next step so this is the
butter wrapper I was saving for so now
I'm adding sugar coating this from Akane
and I set them aside okay let's check
the temperature to 40 I'm gonna start
whisking this egg whites
I'm going to slowly or
so I'm going to whisk this until stiff
peak I think these two in oh so we got
the dough mixture I'm gonna hard like to
scoop just to incorporate and then I'm
going to add back to the whites
despite make more than two you can have
a fancy party I'm kind of going for
homogeneous texture now I'm gonna pour
this in a ramekin I'm I made more than
enough scrape making nice and even you
kind of want to make a line helps it
right open temperature is 375 I'm gonna
bake it for 20 to 30 minutes so now I'm
going to go next step I will need 2/3
cup heavy cream I'm going to bring it to
a boil or it's heating I'm gonna just
like break some chocolate I am using
dark chocolate 72% because cake mix
already had a lot of sugar so I don't
want to add any more sweet it's all
about balance
you know like texture flavor life so it
stopped boiling so I'm gonna add okay I
just have to melt this into heavy cream
and make it kind of smooth texture it
once it's kind of seconds it's done
yeah it's good now it's fancy time
Rahmani
a 1 tablespoon to start i think
chocolate and alcohol goes well and
especially graham manya it's orange
cognac so chocolate and orange goes well
in my opinion so this is a great liqueur
for this dessert
so just make it fancy I'm gonna put this
little picture now I'm gonna pull them
from the oven look look at this I wasn't
gonna make it giant but helping to be
giant so look I'll Alvin Carl doll I'm
going to finish this up I found some
powdered sugar kind of wanna poke a hole
and odd chocolate inside and I'm done
[Music]
super fancy welcome aria
thank you so much for having me I
recommended you to pour
[Music]
can you guess what it's the king I I
could believe that you can make the card
box cake box cake you made this with box
cake yeah so you please show me how to
do it left to right so make it funky and
you kind of have to help me
oh hey does you have your handy handle
yeah okay three two one make it fancy
yes this is right this is so good
yay Wow did I make you fun oh you made
it fancy yeah do that
three two one make me fancy that's
always the huge body yeah what could you
make into a souffle cereal box cake mix
oh wow I like to eat eating is one of
life's only pleasures Maggie Fanny thank
you so much for watching I encourage you
to make a home if you do tag me on
Instagram and until next time make it
fancy
[Music]
you
[Music]